I think it's hard ball and he's
supposedly Jewish I'm in Washington DC
on a packs annual policy conference
AIPAC is the powerful pro-israel lobby
group that works to make sure that
America has bought Israel's back
politically militarily and economically
now it's an election year and as a
matter of policy AIPAC says they invite
every active campaigning ended it and
everybody showed up except on Bernie
Sanders so did burn you just for an
AIPAC I think so I think it a Jew that
doesn't support other Jews is the worst
kind of you it's a little embarrassing
for us in my opinion I didn't realize
this until Saturday the rabbi inertial
was like how sad is it that the only
Jewish candidate is the only candidate
not going to AIPAC Bernie said that he's
out in the West campaigning because
those are important states for him and
he wanted to submit a video message and
a packed bed no thanks do you can lose
some credit there
the other ones he's campaigning there
this could be considered campaigning
here he has said that he wants to pursue
a level playing field between Israel and
Palestine and he's also big on not you
know taking special interest money or be
beholden to special interests so do you
see his absence here as being consistent
with that no I think this is a great
platform when you've got 18,000 people
that you know I have come out to here
you know all the political parties talk
it is mellitus you feel absolutely the
fact that Bernie Sanders doesn't come as
that disqualifying in your mind well I'm
not a big supporter of him to start with
although I'd love to have you know
Jewish grandfather in the White House so
it's not a deal-breaker him not being
there